what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and yes it finally
freaking happened after over 50 chapters
and over a year in real world time the
black bulls have finally been reunited
with yami and our boy yami is actually
conscious and talking to his squad we've
waited so long for this moment it was so
wholesome and so hype and yet there is
no time to celebrate the second gate of
the cliff off is already opening new
highest ranked devils including lucifer
in his true body are about to arrive and
since this is black clover you know that
everyone is definitely and totally in
danger of dying so let's get into it if
you guys enjoy these black lower videos
and you want to see more in the future
you know what to do just leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it helps with the youtube algorithm
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications you
can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror finally this
video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned in the
previous chapter all the black bulls
assembled and after an incredibly hype
reunion they managed to incapacitate
morris before setting off to liberate
captain yami in this chapter we start
things off with an important yami
flashback in the flashback yami is just
a young man who only recently received
his clover kingdom grimoire because his
unique dark magic is such a mysterious
and rare magic many people feared yami
and thought that he would bring
misfortune to everyone around him the
fact that he was one of the only
foreigners in the clover kingdom also
contributed to him being shunned by much
of society as a foreigner with a
mysterious sinister looking magic he was
a big unknown to the citizens of the
clover kingdom and because of that they
feared him however julius didn't fear or
ostracize yami just the opposite he was
extremely impressed with yami's magic
and he wanted to learn more about it
after meeting and befriending julius
yami was brought into the magic knights
he met knocked and morgan and he met
many other mages who would end up
becoming powerful magic knight captains
so yami eventually did make friends in
the clover kingdom despite being a
foreigner with a strange magic that said
this chapter is definitely placing a
strong emphasis on the nature of yami's
magic the chapter really wants us to
keep dark magic in mind and how this
magic has shaped yami's life since his
youth we also learned that morgen was
especially influential on yami's early
life morgan told yami that the nature of
his magic doesn't matter magic is only
as good or evil as the one who wields it
and since yami is a good person there is
nothing sinister about his dark magic
his dark magic will be used for good
back then yami didn't show much interest
in the magic knights and he certainly
didn't show any interest in becoming a
magic knight captain but after the
tragic death of morgen something in yami
changed he decided that he needed to
form his own magic knights brigade and
since all the respectable people already
had magic knight captains who would be
interested in them yami decided to make
a squad for the misfits of society those
who had bad luck in life those who lost
their way those were outcasts and made
mistakes in the past yami decided to get
as strong as possible so that he would
be worthy of becoming a magic knight
captain and once he did that he set
about recruiting all of the black bulls
that we know and loved today yami wanted
to give these misfits and outcasts a
place to belong a place where they could
use their magic freely and be themselves
but in truth by forming the black bulls
the one who was really given a place to
belong was yami himself the black bulls
became yami's family and he no longer
felt like a lonely ostracized outcast
because all the black bulls could now be
outcasts together this was honestly so
heartwarming for all of his quirks and
aggressive personality traits yami truly
loves his squad and they mean everything
to him yami is like my favorite
character in the whole story alongside
asta and his defining feature has always
been his incredible strength and general
badassery but there was always something
more to yami a deeply kind and caring
inner core we've always known about it
but now the story is actually focusing
on that aspect of yami and i absolutely
love it i've always wanted to learn more
about yami and about the mysterious land
that he came from so i do hope that
we're going to continue to learn about
him in the coming chapters we then jump
to a flashback of morris talking about
yami's magic after he had already been
captured by zena according to morris
dark magic is imbued with the magical
power of the underworld so apparently
dark magic is a magic that is somehow
directly connected to the devils and the
underworld that explains why dark magic
was actually effective against zagred as
a creature of the underworld zagred was
not resistant to dark magic because dark
magic is connected to the underworld
itself anyway morris says that he needs
dark magic to die william's world tree
magic black and this is what will allow
the underworld to connect directly to
the human world through the cliff off
morris sees yami as the chosen one as
someone destined to bring death despair
and darkness into this world his dark
magic is the key to the cliff
and it is because of his magic that the
cliffhoth will be opened and the human
world will be destroyed in this sense
morris is essentially implying that all
of the fears that the clover kingdom
citizens had about yami were actually
true he really was destined to bring
misfortune to everyone but morris can
say what he wants we know that our boy
yami would never accept such a fate and
he will fight against destiny itself if
he has to with his black bulls by his
side then back in the present we see the
black bulls rushing towards yami and
calling out his name with morris still
incapacitated yami is able to open his
eyes and then he begins to laugh he asks
the black bulls whether they really like
him that much and as they respond yeah
we do all at the same time yami says so
do i you idiots yes after over 50
chapters and over a year in real world
time yami is finally reunited with the
black bulls i loved this moment and
honestly i've been waiting for it for a
long time as i said earlier yami is one
of my favorite characters and i
absolutely love the black bulls they are
easily one of the best squads in anime
so seeing them all together again is
freaking beautiful even knocked is there
to witness all of this although he seems
to be keeping his distance and it looks
like he's like sitting up on the roof
referring to the black bulls he says
you're all a bunch of lunatics i'll give
you that and yeah that makes sense we
know that knocked is super anti-social
but i get the feeling that even he has a
soft spot in his heart for the black
bulls everything seems to be great at
this point the long-awaited reunion is
finally here but then the second gate is
already opening the black bulls have
just reunited with yami after all this
time and they assembled in the same
place for the first time in a very long
time but as i predicted in my previous
black clover videos the black bulls will
not have any time to celebrate yes they
finally reached yami and they might even
successfully rescue him but then they're
going to have to turn right around and
fight all the devils that are about to
come into the human world from the
second gate of the underworld and this
will apparently include lucifer in his
true body and while yeah it kind of
sucks that the black bulls can't
celebrate their achievement this is also
going to be absolutely hype and if
mimosa could show up and heal yami right
about now then we might get to see all
the black bulls fighting it out against
lucifer and the other devils and that
would be amazing after all that emphasis
on yami's dark magic i can't wait to see
him in action again and i can't wait to
see what dark magic is truly capable of
in terms of fighting the devils let me
know what you guys think are you hyped
for this epic reunion and are you
excited for the battle against lucifer
also why do you think that yami received
a clover grimoire even though he is a
foreigner and why exactly do you think
that his magic is connected to the
underworld is it all just a coincidence
the luck of the draw
or is there something more that we're
going to learn later finally is morris
really ko'd already or is he actually
going to recover and do something
definitely share your thoughts down in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
black clover video and you want us to
keep it coming just leave a quick like
it only takes a second but it helps a
lot and if you're new to anime pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all if you don't do
that you're still going to miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror a big thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible special thank you
to alpha sigma this man is an absolute
mad lad and a disciple of lord twego
himself i also can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans including ingrata
algital
hinokami in water the toasted cheek
corey mcgowan the spike kaido might be a
gyarados dylan isidor spidey life canal
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist monkey d
quilly cody hebert and jeremy cummings
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red haired ravens steelers
on hell cruise very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks joanne garcia fat boy games
jessica rabbit and jeremy phillips if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you